the effort to strike a deal on a relief
package as you heard chris talking about
a careful dance for lawmakers
on both sides of the aisle with 50
members on each side and you heard
down just one for the republicans now
little room often little appetite for
compromise christina raffini is at the
white house this morning
where the president is playing paying
close attention to the voting in the
senate christina good morning
good morning the white house says the
president and his team have been in
close contact with senate democrats
trying to work out a compromise to this
american rescue plan that everyone can
agree with
but as my surprisingly rested colleague
chris van cleeve just mentioned
this particular bill has had a hard time
navigating capitol hill
and last night was no exception but we
are going to power through
and finish this bill however long it
takes
it took all night and into this morning
thanks in part to a lengthy timeout on
friday
where both sides gridlocked over a
series of last-minute amendments to the
president's 1.9
trillion dollar coveted relief bill this
isn't a pandemic rescue package
it's a parade of left-wing pet projects
that are ramming through
they're ramming through during a
pandemic
the biggest sticking point how much
extra money to give 11 million
out of work americans extended
unemployment benefits are set to expire
in just a few weeks
the white house said late last night
that president biden supported the
compromise
300 instead of 400 dollars a week to get
the bill
passed we can't afford one step forward
and two steps backwards
we need to beat the virus provide
essential relief and build an inclusive
recovery
people need to help now stacy rodriguez
says the help she needs will come from
the bill's fourteen hundred dollar
stimulus check
it would mean i'd be able to pay my
mortgage this month would mean i'd be
able to eat
i would be able to buy her medications
that aren't covered
she's struggling to cover her daughter's
medical expenses and says
that amount of money is the difference
between making it
or not the things that we need are
endless right now and
and it would actually give us a little
bit of hope
like hope or we can concentrate on her
physical health or mental health and try
to pull us together and make it
the president had said all along he
wanted bipartisan support for this
legislation
he didn't get it but for many struggling
americans it's less important how the
bill passes
than it actually passing and how soon
they can start to see that relief the
president promised them
michelle all right christine our
well-rested christina ruffini thank you
so much